do the Palestinians have a right to a
septic State no I don't think they do
but in 2007 the head of military
intelligence for the Israeli Army had a
meeting with the US ambassador in Tel
Aviv we're looking at the classified
cable that summarizes what was talked
about in this
meeting the topic of discussion was Iran
Syria the Gaza Strip and
Hamas Hamas had just won the Palestinian
elections which kicked off a fight with
the other Palestinian Group which ended
in Hamas taking over Gaza completely
they controlled it and if you're an
Israeli citizen or the US government
this is a terrible set of events a Hamas
is a violent extremist group known to
commit heinous violence against
civilians in Israel and they were now in
power they controlled the Gaza Strip an
hour away from Tel Aviv but look at this
leaked document in this leaked cable you
see that the Israeli official says that
Israel would be happy if Hamas took over
Gaza because it would mean that Israel
could now treat Gaza like a hostile
country 3 days post the ceasefire and
there's unrelenting bombing in Gaza this
document is a view into a strategy that
right-wing factions within the Israeli
government have used for decades in an
effort to win one of the most divisive
conflicts in the world today in which
two groups are fighting over one piece
of Holy Land and one side is winning by
using a very specific tactic one that
the world says is illegal and immoral
and one that worked for a short time but
that recently has been shown to be a
recipe for even worse violence and
conflict and
suffering in this video I want to lay
out what this strategy looks like and
show you how it failed I know this is a
topic that is full of Deep Emotions that
has real stakes in people's lives please
know that I am Earnest in my effort to
tell this story with Clarity and with
accuracy and also please note that this
is not a full account of the conflict
between Israel and its neighbors but I
do hope that it sheds light on a view of
the conflict that sometimes gets lost in
all of the
[Music]
yelling
for 2,000 years Jewish people around the
world have been persecuted and
segregated and ostracized from society
that is a fact by the time the 1800s
came around it became clear that
wherever the Jews went persecution would
follow
[Music]
this is when a movement emerged calling
for Jews to come together and to create
a country for themselves where they
could govern themselves and be free from
all of this racist hatred the creation
of a Jewish country would have at the
top of its priority list the security of
the Jewish people but the big question
was where several places floated around
in proposals Argentina even modern day
Kenya which back then was
Uganda
but most people in this movement wanted
the Jews to return to their historic
Homeland a place called
Palestine where Jews built their Temple
and their culture 3,000 years ago but
then were exiled and now there was this
call to return so that Jews could feel
safe after 18 centuries of Jewish
suffering so as the 1900s came around
tens of thousands of Jews most mostly
from Europe flocked to
Palestine which eventually came under
control of the British the British were
getting ready to leave this region and
were struggling to contain the growing
conflict between native Arabs and all
these Jewish immigrants then in the
1940s came a horrific genocide against
the Jewish people in Europe Led Out by
Hitler and his Nazi
regime this created a wave of
international support for this idea of
giving the Jewish people a Homeland
where they could be safe before they
left the British asked the UN to
determine what would replace them in
Palestine and the UN decided that
Palestine would become two new countries
one for the Jews and one for the
Palestinian Arabs that had already been
living in this region the Jewish State
colored light the Arab State dark Jeffer
to go to the Arabs Jerusalem
internationalized but as happens when
Outsiders draw lines on Old Land there
was a problem here with Within These
borders that were meant for the new
Jewish country hundreds of thousands of
Palestinian Arabs were living who would
soon have to leave their homes to move
to their side of the
[Music]
line okay wait I'm going to pause there
because as I said this is not a full
history of the Arab Israeli conflict we
actually just made a video on our new
channel search party which focuses on
what happens next the conflict between
is and its Arab neighbors you can go
watch that links in the description
it'll give you some useful context for
now just note that this led to a
horrific conflict Jewish Milas forced
over 700,000 Arabs out of their homes
turning them into refugees the proposed
border shifted around turned into
ceasefire lines and after all was said
and done the Jewish people did indeed
get their own country the state of
Israel and the two important points here
are that number one the very foundation
of the Israeli country is for security
of the Jewish people after nearly 2,000
years of persecution and number two the
location they chose to set it up was
becoming as a result of this conflict
not much safer than
Europe that's a tension that follows
this whole
story okay so now let's fast forward to
1967 Israel has its country and they
fight a short war with their Arab
neighbors and they win that war and they
take over all of this
land it's a huge victory for them I'm
going to take away the C Peninsula from
here because they did give that back to
Egypt as part of a peace deal a few
years later Israel Now controls
important pieces of land that enlarge
their Jewish
country many saw this Victory as a sign
from God that they were actually
entitled to be here but once again
Palestinians nearly a million of whom
had been kicked out of their homes were
living here in the West Bank and the
Gaza Strip which Israel now controlled
but they weren't really sure what to do
with it and it's this territory that
would become the stage for the strategy
that is the topic of this video where
over time this land would be sliced up
with roads and checkpoints walls and
other military infrastructure that would
control the movement and lives of the
Palestinians soon even Israeli citizens
would start to move out here in large
numbers building full-on towns and
further divid in up this territory
moving citizens into occupied territory
like this is something that the world
has deemed illegal and
immoral so this occupation starts in
1967 and it goes on for decades till
eventually the Palestinians living here
can't handle it anymore and they start
fighting
back this is known as the first Uprising
or
inif it started with boycotts but but
escalated into Mass protests where
Palestinians of all ages would throw
stones and sometimes Molotov cocktails
at much better equipped Israeli soldiers
it was Palestinian rage exploding
against Israeli occupation and it went
on for years the Israeli government
would respond by cracking down killing
many
Palestinians another important thing
that happens around the same time down
in the occupied Gaza Strip is that a new
movement forms promising to fight back
against this occupation calling for the
destruction of Israel the group is
called
Hamas the first intifa showed that this
wasn't going to work chopping up
Palestinian land oppressing them keeping
them in this occupation was only going
to produce more violence it wasn't going
to fulfill Israel's promise to provide
security and safety for the Jewish
people they had to switch course the
security of the Israeli people will be
reconciled with the hopes of the
Palestinian people and there will be
more security and more hope for all so
in the 1990s they start getting serious
about peace talks with the Palestinians
and they come to this agreement called
the Oslo
Accords which for the first time
establishes a Palestinian government
Authority and giving it power to govern
pockets of land in the West Bank it also
gave the Palestinians some authority
over almost all of the Gaza Strip though
there were still settlements in all of
these
places this was a big deal for this
conflict like both sides were talking to
each other and coming to agreements that
was giving like authority to the
Palestinians but another theme of the
story is that hardliners can use
violence to derail peace that's exactly
what happened
here right-wing Israelis start holding
rallies calling their prime minister a
traitor and a Nazi for giving land to
the Palestinians some of these rallies
are led by a now familiar character
Benjamin Netanyahu the people of Israel
want a real peace and real peace means
peace with security peace they can trust
with a partner they can trust and they
don't feel to have it here we want a
real peace not a fake one but the peace
talks continue with all our neighbors a
comprehensive peace and shortly after
signing the second part of this deal to
give Palestinian some land the Prime
Minister Yak Rabin is assassinated by a
far-right
Israeli Hamas conducts bus bombings and
the next year Benjamin Netanyahu is
elected as the prime minister of Israel
Netanyahu is a key figure in this story
because his worldview embodies a way of
thinking that is taken root in Israel in
recent years the idea that the only way
to give true security to the Jewish
people is by doing whatever is necessary
to stop the Palestinians from having a
state anywhere in these
[Music]
borders look I'm 28 years old I've had
to defend my country in two Wars and in
many batt nobody wants peace more than
Israel but the stumbling block to the
road for peace is this demand for a PL
state which will mean war war which will
mean more violence in the Middle East
and I think I sincerely believe if this
demand is abandoned we can have real and
genuine peace so that was Netanyahu he
was a 28-year-old but when he becomes
the Prime Minister a couple decades
later he spends his term sabotaging the
Peace Accords that his predecessor had
worked so hard to create claiming that
the occupation of all this land and its
people wasn't actually Conquest but
rather the key for security of the
Jewish people they had to do this
security was the one and only
justification for all of this so under
his watch seders continue to move into
the West
Bank we found this leaked video of
Benjamin Netanyahu talking to some
settlers in the West
Bank the cameraman does turn off the
camera for a moment moment but then
turns it back on moments
later he is admitting to sabotaging the
Peace Accords that the Israeli
government had signed with the
Palestinians that because he disagreed
with them he wanted to sabotage them
because he was so against a Palestinian
state or any form of Palestinian
autonomy in this land and then he goes
on to explain what his real thinking is
on the
[Music]
situation nahu is a fantastic politician
and Statesman and he's able to sort of
cover up a lot of these policies in the
name of
security but here we see what he really
thinks as he's talking to these settlers
thinking he's not being recorded So
unsurprisingly the appetite for peace
breaks down on both sides Palestinians
come to the conclusion that the Israelis
aren't really serious about giving them
any kind of autonomy in the West Bank or
Gaza that their situation will never
change and once again they rise up in a
second intifa this one much more violent
much more
[Music]
coordinated Hamas becomes a major player
in the violence with suici bombings and
attacks Israel responds with great force
and during the fighting a th000 Israelis
and 3,000 Palestinians are killed at
this point the Netanyahu way of seeing
the world is starting to look a lot
better peace talks didn't work all they
did was produce more violence and so
maybe the only way to ensure Security is
to go back to full-blown occupation of
controlling every move of the
Palestinians in the West Bank and the
Gaza Strip so at this point the
occupation gets more and more
suffocating more walls more barriers
more checkpoints more
settlements then in 2005 Israel
withdraws from the Gaza Strip letting
the Palestinian Authority have total
control there they turn their attention
entirely to their historic homeland of
Judean Samaria which is the West Bank
the next year an election is held in the
Palestinian authorities and the winner
surprised the world and would create a
new chapter for this conflict the winner
of these elections was Hamas this is a
very very bad results for the
Palestinians and for
Israel the incumbent Palestinian party
that had lost the election tried to
forcibly hold on to power and soon the
two Palestinian parties were fighting
with each other and it results in this
split between the two Palestinian
governments it turns into violence and
when the dust settles there's suddenly a
bitter divide between these two
Palestinian groups Hamas completely
taking over the Gaza Strip
and this gets us back to our leaked
document that we started this video with
where an Israeli official is saying that
they would actually be happy if Hamas
took over the Gaza Strip because now
they can treat Gaza like a hostile
country now that they're not occupying
it they're not responsible for the 2
million civilians who are living there
they can impose a blockade to control
anything coming in and out of the Gaza
Strip people food medicine money
building supplies but there was another
reason why Israel was happy that Hamas
now controlled the Gaza Strip the
Palestinian government was now deeply
divided Hamas ruling Gaza and the West
Bank being run by a more moderate
secular Palestinian faction and
crucially neither considered the other
to be legitimate which weakened their
ability to negotiate for any kind of
State for any kind of country especially
when Hamas still refused to recognize
Israel's right to even exist this
division played right in into the hands
of the Israeli
right and this gets us back to Benjamin
Netanyahu that enemy of the earlier
peace
talks he gets elected once again in 2009
declaring himself Mr security and
promising to provide safety to Israeli
citizens who are still shaken from the
second intifa and are now worried that
Hamas Now controls the entirety of the
Gaza Strip nyah's Playbook was already
made clear he had set it point blank to
what he had been doing for years
sabotaging peace talks that would give
Palestinians any kind of authority over
this land and continuing to build
settlements while continuing in his
words in that leaked tape to hit the
Palestinians hard to make it unbearable
for them a complete assault on the
Palestinian government dividing and
slowly Conquering the Palestinian people
making life hard and desperate for them
controlling their lives watching their
every move and this is where we get to
this paradoxical alignment almost
alliance between Benjamin Netanyahu and
Hamas the enemy of
Israel as long as Hamas held control
over the Gaza Strip the Palestinian
cause would remain weak and divided
Netanyahu would feel justified in
imposing this crippling blockade of the
Gaza Strip which in turn gave Hamas
legitimacy among the people of the Gaza
Strip showing that their arms struggle
against Israeli oppression was justified
provoking them to launch rockets into
Israel to show that they were actually
doing something unlike the Palestinian
Authority in the West Bank which in turn
bolstered netanyahu's narrative that the
Palestinians actually don't want peace
they want violence and the destruction
of Israel and the only way for security
is more occupation more
[Music]
oppression so instead of try to take
Hamas out Netanyahu overtly supported
them by approving huge transfers of
untraceable cash literally delivered in
suitcases into the Gaza Strip cash that
would inevitably end up in the hands of
Hamas to be used against Israel he
legitimized Hamas by negotiating with
them releasing a thousand Palestinian
prisoners in exchange for one Israeli
the Israeli soldier held captive by
Palestinian militants for 5 years is
expected to be freed within days the
more Netanyahu could keep Hamas in power
in Gaza but keep them contained the more
he could ensure that Palestinians remain
divided he could keep peace talks from
ever happening which in turn gave him
time to continue to pursue his
expansionist project in the West Bank
and indeed since 2009 when Netanyahu
became the Prime Minister the number of
settlements in the West Bank has only
gone
up and if you look at this map you can
see how these settlements just weave
through and carve up this land making it
impossible to even fathom what a
Palestinian State could look like which
is precisely the point of the
strategy I actually reported out here
visiting the settlements back when I was
at Vox I did a series talking to the
settlers trying to understand why they
live out there what it's like to live in
these settlements that are strangely
peaceful and benol and just mundane
people living their lives because
they're protected by the Army if you
want a deeper dive on settlements you
can go watch that series but if you're
netan over the last 16 years you think
your plan is working like you see all
these settlements going up the
International Community can't do
anything about it they keep supporting
you every once in a while there's some
flare up in the West Bank where
Palestinians get into a fight with
Israeli soldiers but it gets contained
every few years Hamas fires some Rockets
which then gives Israel the excuse to go
as they put it cut the grass by
conducting a short Swift violent
military campaign to keep Hamas at Bay
and every day that goes by the notion of
a Palestinian state becomes less and
less
feasible this is one reason why a
far-right Israeli lawmaker called Hamas
an
asset so dividing conquer has been the
name of the game in Israel for a long
time but especially in the last 16 years
under Netanyahu and again to the people
in charge they think it's working maybe
this violent status quo this equilibrium
can hold and the far right can get
exactly what they want is security for
the jewi people and expansion into all
of this land and maybe the occupation
will break the Palestinian spirit and
they would give up on their dream of
having a state but that's not what
happened on October 7th 2023 we saw how
wrongheaded this theory of security was
in an unprecedented surprise attack the
militant Hamas rulers of Gaza sent
dozens of Fighters into Israel by land
sea and air this deadly attack launched
by Hamas showed us that while
netanyahu's strategy of divide and
conquer might be good for taking over
more land what it's not good for is
making good on the original promise of
Israel which is ensuring the security of
the Jewish people in fact his strategy
has produced exactly the
[Music]
opposite now the responsibility for what
happened on October 7th lies with the
people who committed those acts of
Terror Hamas Fighters and their leaders
there is no excuse or justification for
their actions but the point I'm trying
to make with this video is that there's
also others that need to stand
accountable here those who used Hamas as
a pawn to continue this divide and
conquer policy who are now engaged in a
campaign of mass Bloodshed on civilians
they deserve to stand accountable as
well to the Israeli people and to the
countries that support Israel I believe
in the need for a Jewish State I do I
think that's a very reasonable proposal
that Jewish people people should feel
safe somewhere in this world and yet
what we're looking at isn't it the
Israeli project the way that it's been
wielded in its current form produces the
exact opposite of security for the
Jewish people thanks for watching and I
know that you probably have thoughts and
I'm sure a lot of you disagree with what
I've said here and that's okay I want to
hear from you I want to listen to that
and I will see you down in the comments
today's video we didn't have a normal
sponsor because a lot of people right
now don't want to be attached to this
discussion but luckily I can tell you
about something that is a big support to
our journalism which is nebula nebula is
a platform where we publish all of our
videos ad free it is a platform that is
run and owned by creators which is makes
a big difference for a lot of reasons
but it is a place where creators like me
who like to learn about the world
publish their stuff on nebula you'll
also find stuff that you can't find
anywhere else stuff that's exclusive to
the nebula platform these are called
nebula Originals stuff like modern
conflicts by real life lore is extremely
rigorous and well told and explains how
Wars are fought today and again you
can't watch it anywhere else the other
thing I love about nebula is that I find
new creators and new shows here like
this is a new series called red atoms
it's about the Soviet nuclear program
and it's just really high quality stuff
it's very similar to what you see here
but you can't get it anywhere else it's
not on YouTube there are loads of these
kinds of series on nebula and when you
sign up you support the creators who
make this stuff including us here we're
trying to do independent journalism and
deep dive investigations and visual
explainers and it's a big effort we have
a big team of people that make this all
happen when you sign up for nebula using
the link in our description some of your
monthly subscription goes directly to
our team so that we can continue to do
this so that we can grow so that we can
do more ambitious things the link is
nebula.jpg the link and if you're going
to sign up for this use that link it is
$2.50 a month if you sign up for the
annual thing it's five bucks a month if
you do the monthly thing you can cancel
any time so sign up for nebula support
us watch a bunch of exclusive stuff it's
nebula.jpg
[Music]